Schöner.
Freier.
Fitter.
Fortschrittlicher.
Entspannter.
Nachhaltiger.
Sechs Menschen
auf ihrem ganz eigenen Weg,
ihr Leben zu verbessern.
* Rasante Musik *
Ich bin Saskia (28)
und Informatiktrainerin für
Sehbehinderte im beruflichen Umfeld.
Ich mache die nächsten vier Wochen
ein Experiment
zum Thema Selbstvermessung.
Dazu nutze ich Apps und Gadgets,
v.a. in den Bereichen Fitness,
Ernährung und Erholung.
So möchte ich sehen, wie ich
mein Leben damit optimieren kann.
Ich habe mich
vor einigen Monaten verletzt.
Ich komme jetzt gerade
aus einer Verletzungsphase raus,
darf jetzt also wieder
mit Sport starten.
Ich möchte in dreieinhalb Wochen
beim Spartacus Run in Sursee
mitlaufen.
Das sind etwa 6,5 km
mit mindestens 20 Hindernissen.
Da muss ich was tun.
Wenn ich mich nicht optimiere,
schaffe ich das nicht.
Ich fülle meine Excel-Liste aus,
um meine Ziele zu definieren
und die dann zu überprüfen.
Ich würde gerne versuchen,
mindestens 7 Std. zu schlafen,
damit ich beim Sport fitter werde.
Und ich möchte 6 kg abnehmen.
Ich messe drei Bereiche:
Fitness, Ernährung und Erholung.
Es sind ja schon viele Daten,
die ich persönlich sammeln möchte.
Und ...
Ja, da schaue ich, wie ich das
am besten darstellen kann.
Ich hätte am Schluss
auch gerne ein Diagramm,
was mir farblich zeigt,
wo ich stehe
und was ich noch machen muss.
Und ich möchte auch wissen,
was ich überhaupt schaffe.
Es ist ganz klar eine Selbst-
reflexion und Motivation für mich.
Und ich mag es gerne aufgeschrieben,
was ich mache und tun muss.
Ich hab gerne Hilfe -
Hilfe von den Apps.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich würde gerne Gewicht verlieren
und meine Ausdauer steigern.
Und daher an Trainingstagen
1'700 Kalorien.
Und wenn ich jetzt mal nichts mache
oder weniger,
dann auch weniger Kalorien.
Ich koche jetzt eine Shakshuka.
Ich stelle meine Ernährung
dahingehend um,
dass ich weniger Kohlenhydrate esse.
Das kennt jeder.
Aber was ich Besonderes
machen möchte:
Ich möchte auf Getreide,
Milchprodukte
und komplett auf Zucker verzichten.
Die Technik und Vermessung
helfen mir dabei zu sehen,
was überhaupt
in den Lebensmitteln drin ist.
Ich habe jetzt gerade
meine Ernährungstrack-App geöffnet,
um meine Zutaten einzugeben
und zu scannen.
Sie hat mich schon daran erinnert,
dass ich mein Abendessen
eingeben soll.
Also, das passt gerade.
Ich kann das hier jetzt scannen.
Mal schauen, ob es das gibt.
Ich halte es unter die Handykamera.
Ja, dann wird mir das angezeigt.
Ich kann dann entscheiden,
ob das richtig ist.
Und ich kann auch
die Portionen aussuchen.
Das war jetzt ein Tablespoon.
Eine Paprika z.B. ist
in einer normalen Grösse hinterlegt.
Ich könnte sie auch wiegen.
Das wäre noch besser.
Die würde ich dann einzeln eingeben.
So gibt es dann eben
das Gericht insgesamt.
Und so weiss ich ganz genau,
wie viele Kalorien drin sind,
ohne dass ich mich darauf
verlassen muss, was draufsteht.
Hey, Siri!
* Klingelzeichen *
(Weibliche Computerstimme)
Schiess los!
Timer: 10 Min.
* Klingelzeichen *
Okay, 10 Min. -
und der Countdown läuft.
Meine Ernährung umzustellen
fällt mir in gewisser Weise schwer.
Ich würde lügen,
wenn ich sagen würde:
"Nö, das ist alles easy!"
Ich glaube, die ersten paar Tage
sind gar nicht so schlimm,
denn dann ist die Motivation
noch sehr gross, das durchzuziehen.
Schlimm wird es erst,
wenn man unterwegs ist und merkt:
"Oh,
jetzt sollte ich eigentlich essen!"
Und alles, was ich bekomme,
z.B. beim Bäcker,
darf ich nicht essen,
weil kein Getreide.
Und dann
fällt es einem schon schwer.
Ich komme aus einer Verletzung.
Genauer habe ich mir vor vier Wochen
ein Aussenband im Fuss gerissen.
Und davor hatte ich eine schwere
Schädel- und Halswirbelprellung
durch einen Reitunfall.
Und jetzt ist heute das erste Mal,
wo ich wieder laufen gehe.
Ich bin gespannt, wie es läuft.
* Sanfte Musik *
# Here with me.
Ich tracke meine Zielsetzungen
im Fitness
erst einmal mit einer App ...
... und mit einem Gerät,
das die ganzen Parameter misst.
Das wäre in diesem Fall meine Uhr.
Gemessen wird mein Herzschlag.
Gemessen wird mit GPS,
welche Strecke ich laufe.
Und meine Pace.
Das bedeutet,
wie schnell ich überhaupt bin.
Und daran
würde ich mich gerne messen.
Meine grösste Motivation
ist natürlich,
möglichst schnell Ergebnisse
zu sehen und fit zu werden.
Man kann immer sagen:
"Jetzt bin ich besser geworden
und fühle mich besser."
Aber letztlich zählt nur das,
was gemessen wurde.
* Sie keucht. *
Ähm ...
2 km.
Dauer: 12 Min. 51 Sek.
Eine Pace von 6,22 -
also wie viele Minuten ich
für einen Kilometer brauche.
Und ...
Ich habe 238 Kalorien verbrannt.
Und meine Herzfrequenz
war im Durchschnitt bei 177.
Das ist noch ein bisschen hoch.
Der maximale Puls
ist bei mir bei 185.
D.h.,
dann kriege ich keine Luft mehr.
Und er könnte noch
ein bisschen stabiler unten sein.
Aber fürs Erste
ist es schon mal gut.
# Go, motivate, motivate,
motivate, motivate, motivate.
Ich habe auch noch etwas angehängt -
einfach, um zu schauen,
was noch geht und wo mein Limit ist.
Meine Date
wurde bereits in der App gesammelt.
Das habe ich vorhin kontrolliert.
Das steht alles drin.
Ich werde sie zusätzlich noch
in meine Motivation Chart einfügen.
Und ich bin selbst überrascht,
dass ich das geschafft habe.
# Motivate, motivate,
motivate, motivate, motivate.
Der erste Tag war für mich
wirklich sehr überraschend.
Ich habe immer das Gefühl gehabt,
ich kenne mich aus,
was zumindest die Apps betrifft.
V.a. bin ich überrascht
über meinen Run,
dass es so gut lief,
dass ich danach noch Puste hatte.
Und es gibt mir auch Hoffnung,
dass das Ganze
wirklich in der Zeit klappt,
wie ich mir das vorgenommen habe.
Heute treffe ich mich mit Christoph,
um zu rennen
und Kraftübungen zu machen.
Zu zweit
macht es einfach mehr Spass!
14!
Zehn!
Neun!
In Bezug auf Sport
läuft es sehr, sehr gut.
Ich habe ja
mit meinen 2 km angefangen
und das auch
wirklich gerade so geschafft.
Mit meinem Laufplan
bin ich gestern schon 4,5 km
in einer sehr guten Pace gelaufen.
Und jetzt fehlt einfach
noch ein bisschen die Kraft.
* Popmusik *
Die Selbstvermessung
hilft mir in dem Fall sehr gut,
um mich zu motivieren.
Ich habe meinen Plan.
Meine App sagt mir,
wann ich zu laufen habe,
v.a. aber auch,
was ich zu laufen habe.
Und wenn ich das nicht so mitmesse
und nach dem Plan mache,
wäre keine Steigerung
und Entwicklung zu sehen.
Und da hilft mir das wahnsinnig!
* Sie keucht. *
Ich kriege keine Luft mehr.
Danke dir!
Puh! Besser!
Wie viel sind wir jetzt gerannt?
- Das kann ich dir zeigen.
Und zwar ...
Wir müssen noch das Foto machen.
Für unser ... Doch!
Können wir das
nicht jeweils vorher machen?
Nein, das ist extra ...
Das Foto nach dem Rennen
ist extra dazu da, dass man sieht,
was man geleistet hat.
Ich finde das die beste Motivation.
- Ja, ja.
Also,
dann machen wir mal ein Selfie!
Yeah!
- Sehr gut!
Man kann noch eine Notiz hinzufügen
und sagen: "Es war super."
Und dann liest sie es uns vor.
(Computerstimme) Distanz: 2,3 km.
Dauer: 14 Min. 40 Sek.
Durchschnittliche Pace:
6 Min. 21 Sek.
Gut!
- Genau.
Und hier auf dieser Karte
kannst du immer noch erkennen,
an welcher Stelle ich jetzt z.B.,
weil es meinen Puls mass,
im höchsten Pulsbereich war -
also eigentlich wirklich k.o. war.
Und immer, wo es hochging,
sieht man,
wo es runterging,
wie es wieder grün wurde.
Und so
tracke ich jetzt jedes Rennen.
Man kann hier
auch noch den Fortschritt anzeigen.
Und dann sehe ich hier z.B., wie
viele Kilometer ich gelaufen bin,
welche Pace ich im Schnitt habe
und wie viele Kilometer
ich gesamt gelaufen bin.
Mein Jahresziel sind 150 km.
18 davon bin ich schon gelaufen.
Der Fakt, dass mir die App sagt, was
ich zu tun habe, finde ich genial.
Sie schlägt mir einfach etwas vor.
Ich halte mich daran.
Und schlussendlich
kann ich mich darauf verlassen.
Es macht es für mich viel einfacher,
weil ich einfach dem folge,
was mir die App sagt.
Ich bin gerade aufgestanden
und wurde
von meiner Sleep-Cycle-App geweckt -
wie in den letzten paar Wochen auch.
Wenn ich sie abends stelle,
muss ich nur sagen,
wann ich spätestens
aufwachen möchte.
Und dann rechnet sie
im Halbstundenzyklus und schaut,
wann ich am wachsten bin.
Dann fängt sie an, mich zu wecken -
also wie ein ganz normaler Wecker.
Die App trackt zusätzlich
noch meinen Schlaf.
D.h., sie hört mir nachts zu
und kann durch diese Geräuschkulisse
entscheiden,
wie meine Schlafphase im Moment ist.
Dann zeige ich am besten mal,
was die App alles kann.
Ich nehme mal den Schlaf
von heute Nacht.
Da hatte ich die Möglichkeit,
relativ lange zu schlafen.
Das wirkte sich auch
auf die Schlafqualität aus.
Und ...
Ja, die Herzfrequenz
wird morgens eben auch gemessen -
und zwar geht hinten bei der Kamera
das Licht an.
Das Kameralicht und die Kamera
können meinen Herzschlag nachmessen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob die App
den Schlaf wirklich verbessern kann.
Mein grösster Gewinn von der App
ist,
dass ich besser aufwache
und mich so dann auch fitter fühle.
Und ich bin in Bezug auf meinen
Schlaf viel aufmerksamer geworden.
Bubele!
Hallo!
Komm mal her!
Oh Mausi!
Grosses Pferd!
Ja, komm her!
Für mich ist mein Pferd
der einzige Ort,
an dem ich tatsächlich
digital frei bin.
Und deswegen zählt es für mich
v.a. zur Erholung,
weil ich hier
auch mal abschalten kann.
Also ich bin vor zwei Monaten
vom Pferd gefallen.
Ich war auch im Krankenhaus.
Aber es ist für mich ...
... eher die Motivation
zu überdenken:
Was könnte ich denn
noch besser machen?
Wie könnte ich
solche Situationen vermeiden?
Wir gehen hoch auf den Platz.
Er ist noch nicht eingeritten.
Wir arbeiten im Moment
gerade vom Boden aus
und gewöhnen ihn an den Sattel.
Aber es reicht noch nicht,
um frei zu reiten.
* Sanfte Musik *
Komm!
Gut! Prima!
Super!
In meinem Motivation Chart steht,
was ich mir vorgenommen habe und ...
Ja, es gleicht sich immer mehr ab
mit dem,
was ich auch erreicht habe.
Meine grossen Ziele pro Kategorie
waren ja,
dass ich beim Sport fitter werde.
Das habe ich tatsächlich geschafft.
Zum Thema Ernährung sagte ich,
ich wolle 6 kg abnehmen.
Das ist in dreieinhalb Wochen
schon ein bisschen ein krasses Ziel.
Heute Morgen habe ich mich gewogen.
Und ich habe es tatsächlich
geschafft!
Mein Ziel in der Erholung
mit den 7 Std. Schlaf im Schnitt
habe ich auch mit heute
oder gestern schon geschafft.
Das Experiment Selbstvermessung
führte v.a. dazu,
dass ich immer irgendwie
einen Leitfaden hatte,
was ich machen soll, muss und kann.
Kritik an der Selbstvermessung
kann ich eigentlich
nur in dem Punkt geben,
dass man halt sehr, sehr, sehr viel
von sich preisgibt.
Man kann nicht so ganz
kontrollieren,
wo die Daten landen.
Und v.a. verbringt man natürlich
viel Zeit am Handy.
Das sind meine Freunde
jetzt gewöhnt,
aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass es für jemanden,
der das auch gerne versuchen würde,
schwierig sein kann,
denn es kommt viel Druck von aussen.
Das fängt an mit:
"Was trackst du da?
Was machst du da die ganze Zeit?"
"Du schreibst das auf und wiegst
dich mit einer komischen Waage!"
"Was ist,
wenn die Daten rauskommen?"
Ich glaube, es ist eher das Problem,
dass einen die Unsicherheit
von aussen selber unsicher macht.
Das waren meine Goals,
das, was ich erreichen wollte.
Und heute werde ich am Run sein.
Es wird erst abgehakt,
wenn ich es geschafft habe.
* Popmusik *
* Jubel *
* Sie keucht. *
Es gibt noch viel zu tun.
Aber ich ...
Ich bin froh,
dass ich es gemacht habe -
jetzt in dreieinhalb Wochen.
Mir fehlen ein bisschen die Worte.
Ich glaube,
das heute hat mir gezeigt,
dass sich das lohnt,
dass man dadurch
Ziele realistischer erreichen kann.
Ich habe sie
in meinen Alltag eingebaut.
Warum sollte ich es nicht machen?
Ich würde gerne jedem zeigen,
dass es sich lohnt, das anzufangen,
wenn es auch nur mal
für einen Monat ist,
um zu sagen:
"Okay, ich habe das mal gemacht."
Es war sauanstrengend,
aber es hat Spass gemacht!
* Sanfte Musik *
* Popmusik *
An der Langstrasse hast du eigent-
lich jeden Tag so einen Kreislauf.
Die Leute
gehen abends in den Ausgang,
konsumieren ohne Ende.
Ich merke,
dass ich da nicht dazugehöre.
Ich möchte nicht mehr Teil
dieses sinnlosen Abendkonsums sein,
sondern Teil einer Bewegung,
die nach vorne schaut.
Trotzdem
ist es ein sehr schönes Quartier.
Eine grosse Herzensangelegenheit.
Ich bin Carla (27) und wohne
mitten in der Stadt Zürich,
an der Langstrasse.
Ich mache im Moment die Matur
und bin ursprünglich Schneiderin.
Und ich lebe Minimal Waste.
Minimal Waste heisst für mich,
dass ich auf möglichst alles
verzichte, was unnötig ist.
Sprich: Ich kaufe nichts in Plastik.
Ich brauche keinen Halm,
um meinen Drink zu schlürfen.
Ich hatte am Anfang grossen Respekt
vor solchen Sachen wie Zahnpasta
oder Deo auszuwechseln.
Anstatt
einer konventionellen Zahnpasta
benutze ich Kokosnussöl
und Aktivkohle.
Das Kokosnussöl ist
antimikrobakteriell und antifungal.
Es ist toll für alles.
Die Aktivkohle
wirkt ganz leicht abrasiv.
Für ein Rouge
benutze ich ein Randenpulver.
Wenn ich mich schminken will,
mache ich es nass
und streiche es auf die Wangen.
Im Sommer ist mein Deo etwas mühsam:
Kokosnussöl schmilzt ja
ab einem gewissen Punkt.
Jetzt, da es so heiss ist, sowieso.
Aber es geht eigentlich ums Natron,
das im Deo enthalten ist.
Es verhindert,
dass sich Bakterien bilden können.
Du kannst ein bisschen herausnehmen
und dir unter die Achseln streichen.
Es funktioniert
wie ein normales Deo,
aber es bekämpft nicht die Symptome
des Stinkens, sondern die Ursache.
Es entstehen keine Bakterien,
die dann stinken können.
Es gibt natürlich auch Sachen,
die du vorrätig hast aus der Zeit,
bevor du damit begonnen hast.
Ich schätze,
es dauert ein bis eineinhalb Jahre,
bis du all diese Sachen
ausgemustert hast,
also bevor du
mit all deinen Sachen fertig wirst.
Das ist am Anfang recht mühsam,
weil du denkst,
du kommst nicht vorwärts.
Aber du musst sozusagen
über den Berg.
Es dauert sehr lange,
aber es ist okay.
Ich kaufe alles offen ein.
Dann bringe ich es in Taschen
nach Hause
und fülle es in meine Gläser ein.
Somit habe ich halt
keine Verpackung,
sprich ich habe keinen Abfall.
Dort,
wo der Abfall normalerweise ist,
stehen bei mir Küchenmaschinen.
Es ist noch lustig:
Die Leute
gehen automatisch zur Spüle.
Dort suchen sie den Abfall.
Ich sage dann:
"Okay, nein, du darfst es
in dieses Glas legen."
Dann sind sie sehr irritiert,
aber es ist halt ...
Ich habe keinen Abfall mehr,
sondern nur noch ein Glas.
Und das ist gut so.
Ich will das nicht.
Das ist etwa der Abfall
eines Monats.
Und vieles, was da drin ist,
ist Recyclingabfall.
Also so ...
Das stammt z.B. vom Zucker.
Ähm ... Linsen.
Manchmal gönnt man sich Linsen.
Dann ein Stück Holz.
So!
Die etwa ...
Wie viele?
Die etwa sieben Male,
als ich vergass zu sagen:
"Könnte ich den Eiscafe oder Eistee
ohne Halm und Schnickschnack haben?"
Solche Trinkhalme
regen mich total auf.
Ich nehme sie jeweils mit
und denke mir:
"Ich benutze sie
wenigstens noch einmal."
"Dann habe ich nicht nur one way."
Dann: Das ist eine Body Lotion,
die ich vorher hatte
und die jetzt endlich
aufgebraucht ist.
Das ist mein altes Parfüm.
Das habe ich mal mit 18 bekommen.
Es ist neun Jahre alt geworden.
Aber jetzt kommt es weg.
Ich komme nicht darum herum,
Sachen zu wiegen und dann
diese Sticker vom Wiegen zu haben -
ausser,
ich hole die Sachen beim Bauern.
Aber ich habe weder ein Auto, noch
sind die Bauern gut erreichbar.
Ähm ...
Und dadurch ist es wie ...
Eben: Bei gewissen Dingen
kommst du nicht darum herum.
Das ist okay. Es wäre schön,
wenn es andere Optionen gäbe,
aber sich deswegen zu stressen,
ist nicht nötig.
Diese schöne Tonne ist Kompost.
Ähm ...
Es ist wie ...
Wenn du dir den Abfall
in der Schweiz anschaust,
sind 30 % von dem, was wir in die
Kehrichtverbrennung schicken, Essen.
Das ist ein Wurmkompost.
Ähm ...
Jetzt können wir dieses Element
eigentlich wegnehmen.
Da bewegen sie sich.
Das Ziel ist eigentlich, dass aus
deinen Lebzeiten nichts zurückbleibt
und wenn ich mal gehe,
alles mit mir zergehen kann -
so wie ich zu Erde werde,
alles andere zu Erde wird.
Ich habe meistens
einen dieser Metallteller dabei,
einen Becher ...
... und Besteck.
Und wenn ich keins dabeihabe,
frage ich im nächsten Restaurant,
ob ich eine Gabel leihen darf.
Die Leute sind eigentlich easy
und offen.
Serviette und das Portemonnaie.
Ich stelle es da rein.
Der Becher.
Es ist sicher jeden Tag
auch etwas Struggle dabei,
aber es macht so
auch viel zufriedener,
denn ich weiss:
Ich bin nicht part of this shit.
Guten Appetit!
- Danke!
Anina hat einen Blog
über Nachhaltigkeit und Ethik.
Ich nehme gerne
eine Portion Vegane Momos.
Und ich gerne die Veggie-Momos.
Darf ich sie auf dem Teller haben?
- Natürlich!
Und deines ist sogar isoliert.
- Ja.
Das ist noch cool.
Danke vielmals!
- Bitte!
Du beginnst,
dein Umfeld zu optimieren.
Du bist in der Stadt
ganz klar ein Exot.
Das bewegt.
Es ist etwas,
das anders ist und Einfluss hat.
Verglichen mit dem, was ich mache,
ist sie nochmals krasser ein
Spezialist fürs Thema Minimal Waste,
wie sie es nennt.
Und ich fand es sehr toll,
dass meine Community auch mal
die Insights von jemandem bekommt,
der das wirklich stark lebt.
Ich glaube,
man muss schon sehr engagiert sein,
damit man das von einem Tag auf
den anderen alles umsetzen könnte.
Ich sage auch den Leuten, die z.B.
auf vegan umstellen möchten:
Schritt für Schritt ist einfacher,
sodass man sich nicht
mit Erwartungen überfordert,
die man fast nicht erfüllen kann.
Ich sage immer "Minimal Waste".
Es ist nicht der Anspruch,
perfekt zu sein.
Das Ziel ist,
seine beste Option zu finden.
Und das kannst du überall machen.
Es gibt so viele kleine Sachen,
die man verändern kann.
* Sanfte Musik *
So, jetzt nehmen wir noch ...
... ein paar Kerne fürs Müesli
am Morgen.
Dann kannst du dir mit dem Stift -
wie früher in der Schule -
auf die Hand schreiben.
487 g Kerne.
Das ist Natron.
Das ist ein Teil meines Deos.
Es lässt die Bakterien nicht zu,
also die Entstehung von Bakterien.
Die Leute sind noch nicht
so sensibilisiert darauf,
dass es auch unverpackt
möglich wäre.
Und sie sehen halt den Aufwand,
den man im Moment betreiben muss.
So!
Ja.
Den nehme ich mit.
Ich glaube, ohne so einen Laden
Zero Waste zu leben,
wäre viel mühsamer.
Aber wo ein Wille ist,
ist auch ein Weg.
Irgendwie würde es schon gehen.
Vielleicht müsste ich
ein paar Kompromisse mehr eingehen.
Aber ich muss mir diese Gedanken
gar nicht machen,
denn ich habe einen solchen Laden.
Es gibt in Zürich keine Ausrede.
Auf diesem Weg
zu möglichst wenig Verschwendung
bin ich ziemlich nahe bei Tara,
glaube ich.
Sie ist ein bisschen mein Vorbild.
Sie führt den "Zero Waste"-Laden.
103 g Natron.
Natron braucht man immer.
Wie?
- Natron braucht man immer.
Diese "Zero Waste"-Geschichte
inspiriert ja auch
und sucht nach Lösungen.
Und das ist ziemlich toll.
Ich denke, dass wir im Herbst
Tofu im Glas anbieten können.
Dann ist das schon wieder
ein Schritt - ah, toll!
Wieder eine Plastikverpackung
weniger!
16.65 Fr.
- Mit der Karte.
Mit der Karte?
Ich glaube, finanziell gesehen
ist es eine Mischrechnung.
Früher konsumierte ich
sehr viele Kleider
und kaufte günstige Lebensmittel.
Jetzt hat sich das gedreht:
Ich konsumiere sehr wenige Kleider,
aber meine Lebensmittel
sind definitiv teurer.
* Popmusik *
Ich bin hier beim NOERD-Sommerfest,
bei dem es um Zero Waste geht.
D.h.,
die Veranstalter gaben sich Mühe,
dass hier möglichst wenig
Verschwendung stattfindet.
Ich mache mich auf die Suche
nach Tara, die das organisiert.
* Popmusik *
Hallo!
Hallo! Wie geht's dir? Gut?
Du musst immer Boni sagen.
- Das ist auch gut.
Hi!
# You know you want more.
# Less perial.
Es ist immer total schön,
die Fühler
nach Produkten auszustrecken,
die man vielleicht noch nicht hat
und spannend findet.
Schau, das ist der Kompost,
den ich habe!
* Sanfte Musik *
In diese Richtung wollen wir gehen,
oder?
Die Zahnpasta mache ich immer
aus Kokosöl und Aktivkohle.
Ja.
Nein, die machst du selber.
Nein.
Ich habe auch keines mehr gekauft,
wie du siehst.
Ja, aber das ist auch das,
was mir am meisten fehlt.
Dass es das nicht gibt,
nervt mich am meisten.
Ich hatte fünf Jahre lang
blaue Haare.
Sie wurden zu meinem Markenzeichen.
Und jetzt ist so wie der Punkt,
an dem ich sage:
"Wenn ich mir den Berg
an Plastikdosen vorstelle,
den ich benutzen müsste,
um ein Leben lang
blaue Haare zu haben,
haut es mich um."
Es ist total cool!
- Ja, nicht wahr?
Und das Schöne ist, dass es
eine Verbindung zwischen Genuss,
Stil und Lösungsorientierung ist.
Das ist auch das,
was man aufzeigen muss oder will:
Ein nachhaltiges Leben
oder ein umweltfreundlicher Alltag
haben ganz viel mit Genuss, Stil und
gut designten Lösungen usw. zu tun.
Ja.
Ich glaube,
die Leute interessiert es sehr -
die Stände, die wir hier haben.
Ich glaube,
sie haben sehr gute Gespräche.
Man sieht ein paar Fails.
Es ist trotzdem Plastik da.
Oder es werden plötzlich
Ballone verteilt.
Ja.
- Mit solchen Sachen muss man leben.
Und wir lernen daraus.
Es ist wie so ...
Es ist auch ein Experiment.
Ich glaube,
dass wir nicht darum herumkommen,
in Zukunft
Lösungen finden zu müssen.
Dass es jetzt schon Leute gibt,
die dafür brennen,
daran interessiert sind
und aktiv Lösungen suchen,
zeigt ja eigentlich,
dass wir die Kurve
hoffentlich noch bald kriegen.
Bis bald,
wenn ich mal nicht verkabelt bin!
* Lachen *
Viel Spass noch!
- Danke! Ciao!
* Rockmusik *
Drop the gun! You are under arrest.
Ich bin ein Cyborg, weil ich
ein effizienterer Mensch sein will,
nicht ein besserer Mensch.
Aber ich glaube,
dass ich mehr aus meinem
eigenen Leben herausholen kann,
dass ich mehr
aus fremden Leben herausholen kann,
indem ich Denkanstösse verursache.
Also glaube ich, dass ich
ein effizienterer Mensch bin,
aber nicht besser.
Besser müsste man werten,
aber ich sehe das gar nicht wertend.
Für mich ist Fortschritt
der wichtigste Bestandteil
vom Leben.
Ohne Fortschritt
gibt es keine Entwicklung.
Wenn wir jetzt nicht anfangen,
uns selbst zu entwickeln,
den Übermenschen schaffen
und die nächste Stufe,
stagnieren wir für alle Zeiten.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist für mich
weder für die Zukunft
noch für den Menschen sinnvoll.
Ich trage Implantate in mir,
die Funktionen haben.
Ich bin die Mischung
zwischen Mensch und Maschine.
* Sanfte Musik *
# Take a little walk
to the edge of the town.
# Go across the tracks.
Es sieht düster aus,
weil ich gerne düster lebe.
Die Leute nennen mich Grufti,
und ich glaube, das bin ich
im klassischen Sinne auch.
Ich stehe auf Totenköpfe,
Pentagramme und das düstere Zeug.
Ich mag den Grufti-Kitsch!
Angefangen habe ich mit 18.
Wir sind in den Tierhandel gegangen.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Jetzt setze ich mir mal
so ein Teil!"
Wir haben uns so einen Chip gesetzt.
Ich habe ihn mir
in die Handfläche gespritzt.
Ich sagte: "Jetzt lege ich los und
schaue, was ich damit machen kann."
Ich konnte damit
leider nicht viel machen,
weil mir Knowledge
und Community fehlten,
aber ich war neugierig.
Ich fand mich selbst ziemlich cool.
Ich legte einfach los.
In der rechten Hand
trage ich einen Low-Frequency-Chip.
Den sieht man leider nicht,
nur die Narbe.
In meiner linken Hand
sieht man den Chip.
Da ist ein High-Frequency-Chip drin.
Dann habe ich noch einen ganz alten.
Er ist 17 Jahre alt.
Den habe ich hier drin.
Ich habe ihn mir
vom Tierarzt spritzen lassen.
Er ist leider schon tot.
Und dasselbe habe ich hier unten -
auch einen toten Chip.
Was ich machen kann: Ich kann mein
Telefon mit meinem Chip entsperren.
Jetzt muss ich die Stelle finden -
zack!
Jetzt ist das Telefon entsperrt.
Ich kann mir eine Textdatei
als Datensatz hinterlegen,
eine URL zu einer Website,
die ich toll finde,
eine Suchfunktion.
Ich kann mein Facebook-, Twitter-,
LinkedIn-Profil hinterlegen,
wenn ich das sharen möchte,
meinen Steam-Account.
Für die Paranoiden kann ich
mein Bitcoin-Konto hinterlegen.
Ich habe mich für Chips entschieden,
obwohl es auch
mit meinem Gesicht möglich ist,
mein iPhone zu entsperren,
oder mit meinem Fingerabdruck.
Das heisst nicht,
dass der Fingerabdruck
oder das Face-Unlock
weniger praktisch wären.
Im Grunde
ist der Chip unpraktischer,
denn ich muss
einen Vorgang mehr machen.
Aber ich möchte damit
einen Antrieb schaffen.
Ich möchte durch Konsum
Interesse wecken.
D.h., je mehr ich mit Chips,
Upgrades, Wearables usw. konsumiere,
versuche ich mit den Leuten,
die das auch vertreten,
einen Markt zu schaffen.
D.h., wenn wir konsumieren,
wird irgendjemand
irgendwann Interesse haben,
damit Geld zu verdienen.
Meine Bodymodification-
und Subdermal-Implantate
haben effektiv keine Funktion.
Das ist rein, weil ich
mein Aussehen ändern möchte, ja.
# Take a little walk
to the edge of town.
# And go across the tracks.
# Where the viaduct looms,
like a bird of doom.
Ich lernte Mike kennen,
als ich einen Vortrag hielt.
Er meldete sich als Zuschauer.
Wir vertreten uns
in der Öffentlichkeit gegenseitig.
Also wir teilen sehr viel
in unserem Spektrum,
unserer Wahrnehmung,
unserer Realitätswahrnehmung.
Und wir haben den gleichen Gedanken.
Ich wurde von der Fantasy Basel
eingeladen,
über Transhumanismus zu sprechen,
über das Cyborg-Leben,
weil ich mich als Cyborg bezeichne,
um Aufklärung zu betreiben und
den Leuten zu zeigen, was wir tun,
und mit den Leuten zu agieren.
Die Leute hier sind mutig.
Sie sind bereit, sich
in eine andere Rolle zu begeben,
andere Menschen zu akzeptieren
und sich neue Ideen anzuhören.
Ich finde das hier sehr gut passend.
Wir haben gestern
darüber gesprochen:
Du hast gesagt, du würdest jetzt auf
dein physisches Leben verzichten,
um in digitaler Form weiterzuleben.
Du würdest jetzt schon
den Schritt machen und nicht warten.
Absolut!
Hast du keine Angst
vor der Unendlichkeit?
Für mich ist Unendlichkeit
nicht so ein Problem,
denn wenn wir einen Körper haben,
der immer funktioniert,
der immer fähig ist, da ist,
verstehe ich nicht,
warum die Unendlichkeit
ein Problem sein sollte.
Ich möchte ja jetzt
auch nicht sterben,
warum sollte ich in 1'000 Jahren
sterben wollen?
Wenn dein biologischer Körper
irgendwann an sein Ende kommt,
dann lebt einfach
die Maschine weiter,
aber du selbst bist ja trotzdem
an dein Ende gekommen.
Ja, also für mich als Kopie
geht es genau so weiter.
Ich führe dann mein Leben weiter -
halt einfach als Kopie.
Aber die Entwicklung, die danach
stattfindet, das bin weiterhin ich.
Also ich mache
eine digitale Kopie vom Verstand,
vom Gehirn an dem Punkt.
D.h., ich bin eins zu eins dasselbe
an dem Punkt,
an dem ich gespalten werde.
D.h.,
ich verändere mich erst danach.
Habt ihr zu viel Science-Fiction
gesehen?
Ich glaube, Mind uploading ist keine
Fantasie aus der Science-Fiction.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir zu viel
Science-Fiction geguckt haben.
Ich glaube, dass uns Science-Fiction
den Mut gegeben hat,
Wünsche zu äussern.
Dass ein Geist und ein Bewusstsein
digitalisiert werden,
ist tatsächlich irgendwann möglich.
Dass ein Geist an zwei Stellen
digital existieren kann -
als Kopie, als Klon,
wie man das dann auch immer sieht -,
wird auch passieren.
Ob ich es erleben werde,
ist eine andere Geschichte.
Dass man einen Geist in
einen anderen Körper swappen kann,
das ist das Body- oder Wirtswappen,
wird auch passieren.
Wenn du dir vorstellst:
Du bist sterbenskrank.
Du hast die Möglichkeit,
dein Bewusstsein
in einen anderen Körper zu stecken
oder für alle Zeiten
digital weiterzuleben -
die Leute werden das wollen!
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ich kam in die Schweiz,
weil eine Cocktailbar in Basel
einen Barmanager suchte,
was mein Spezialgebiet ist.
Also ich arbeite mit Cocktails.
Ich bin eigentlich
der klassische Barkeeper.
Aber ich arbeite inzwischen
eher in der Geschäftsführung.
Ich kümmere mich um Konzepte,
um das Angebot
und um das,
was administrativ passiert.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Im Beruf merkt man eigentlich nichts
von meinem Privatleben.
Es kann mal passieren,
dass jemand meine Arme sieht
und ihm auffällt,
dass ich Implantate trage.
Grundsätzlich
trenne ich das ganz bewusst.
Ich finde, im Beruf
hat das auch nichts zu suchen.
Mein privates Pleasure soll nicht
im Beruf reflektiert werden.
Der Mensch ist an einem Punkt
angelangt, wo er stagniert.
Wir haben keine Entwicklung mehr.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass ein Mensch glücklich ist,
wenn er auf dem Stand bleibt,
wo er ist.
Eine rein geistige Entwicklung
reicht mir nicht.
Das ist auch für die Zukunft
nicht ausreichend.
Es muss eine körperliche
und physische Entwicklung geben.
Das heisst ja nicht, dass das eine
das andere ausschliessen muss.
Aber das eine
kann durch das andere erfolgen.
Wenn wir eine geistige Entwicklung
durch bewusstes Leben,
bewusstes Konsumieren
von Information usw. durchmachen,
entwickeln wir automatisch
das Bedürfnis,
auch physische Entwicklung zu haben.
Das ist ganz normal.
Wenn du dir über deinen Körper
so bewusst bist,
möchtest du Makel entfernen,
du möchtest Schwachstellen
entfernen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Meine Schilddrüse ist nicht gesund.
Und für mich ist natürlich
ein persönliches Interesse,
dass ich irgendwann
die Schilddrüsenfunktion,
die dieses Ding momentan noch trägt,
mit einer Maschine ersetzen kann.
Ganz klar!
Ich möchte nicht darauf verzichten,
sondern es ersetzen.
Ich möchte nicht fragil sein.
Ich möchte nicht auf
Körperfunktionen verzichten müssen.
Wenn ich die Möglichkeit habe,
meine Schilddrüse,
die nicht richtig funktioniert,
durch eine Maschine zu ersetzen,
die piekfein funktioniert,
solange ich sie anständig behandle,
ist das das absolut Grösste.
Ich würde wohl der Maschine mehr
vertrauen als meiner Schilddrüse.
Menschen, die mir nahestehen,
sind das gewohnt.
Sie sagen:
"Steve spinnt mal wieder!"
"Er macht mal wieder Quatsch,
guckt auf eine Spinnerei
und tut sich das an!"
Man wird viel belächelt,
aber auf eine respektvolle Art
aus meinem Umfeld.
Es gibt tatsächlich Kritiker,
die das sehr verurteilen.
Das gibt es natürlich auch.
Das geht bis zu Beschimpfungen.
Das gehört dazu.
Aber ich wurde noch nie angegriffen
im Sinne von so diffamiert
oder beleidigt, dass ich sagen muss:
"Ich muss das verstecken."
Das auf keinen Fall.
Hallo! Alles fresh?
- Hey!
Und dir?
- Nicht schlecht, danke!
* Sanfte Musik *
Schön, danke!
Es ist etwas grösser als das,
was wir hatten.
Das wird lustig.
Ich lasse mir
ein XBT-Chip-Implantat setzen.
Das Tolle an dem Chip ist:
Er kann meine Körperwärme
an der Stelle,
wo ich ihn implantiere, analysieren,
und ich kann es auswerten.
Dazu könnte man aber auch
einen Fiebermesser benutzen.
Könnte man,
aber ich finde das fetziger.
Es kann einfach sein,
dass ich einen Muskel erwische.
Es ist nicht so schlimm,
wie es klingt.
Ich habe hier
ja auch einen Muskel drin.
Es tut weh,
aber es ist nicht so tragisch.
Aber wenn ich genug nah bin,
geht es.
Ich habe schon einige Chips
bei anderen gesetzt.
bei mir selbst gesetzt.
Und ...
Ja, ich würde sagen,
ich bin darin sehr erfahren.
Wir arbeiten hier steril.
Das sollte eigentlich
kein Problem darstellen.
Der Chip
ist steril in der Nadel drin.
Deswegen sieht man ihn auch nicht,
wenn man ihn implantiert.
Er wird durch die Kanüle
in die Haut gedrückt.
Tja ...
* Steve lacht. *
Dann gehe ich einfach etwa 2 cm ...
Bist du bereit?
Ich glaube, der wird wehtun.
- Das kann sein.
Kann sein.
Shit, der zieht aber!
Warte, er ist gleich drin!
Entschuldige!
* Steve stöhnt. *
Uh!
* Beide lachen. *
Das hat wehgetan, oder?
Das habe ich mir gedacht.
Geht's?
- Alles gut!
Ja, ja, alles cool!
Wo haben wir die Pflaster?
Ah, da!
Tipptopp!
- So!
So!
Danke!
- Bitte schön!
So!
Ich möchte eigentlich
meine komplette Identität
auf meinem Chip haben.
Das fängt beim Schlüssel an,
dass ich meine Tür öffnen darf,
also meine Berechtigung,
meine ID-Karte, am besten auch
meine Bewilligung und mein Geld.
Das möchte ich alles haben.
Ich möchte mich
von diesem Zeug befreien.
Mike kann seine Tür schon öffnen.
Er kratzt aber auch mit den Fingern,
dass er bezahlen darf.
Wir warten eigentlich nur darauf,
dass uns das jemand gestattet.
* Technomusik *
Musik war für mich immer
absolut wichtig -
also in jeglicher Hinsicht, ja.
* Technomusik *
Mein Ziel ist es tatsächlich,
diese ganzen Knöpfe,
die ich hier überall
verteilt habe ...
Das sind ja nichts anderes
als Midi-Trigger.
Hinter jedem Knopf und jeder
Bewegung ist ein kleines Signal.
Das wird
an meinen Computer geschickt,
und der Computer macht das,
was ich hier drücke.
Ich möchte das darauf übertragen.
Das ist ein EEG-Gerät.
Damit kann ich momentan
einen kleinen Orbitkopter steuern.
Das ist ein kleiner Hubschrauber.
Er sieht aus wie eine Drohne.
Mit dem kann ich
drei bis vier Befehle ausführen.
So!
Ich möchte aber jeden Befehl,
den ich hier habe,
mit meinem Übertragungsgerät,
das über Hirnströme funktioniert,
komplett steuern.
Ich triggere eigentlich Befehle,
indem ich daran denke, ja.
Das ist mal eine Konzentration!
Das sind die Hirnwellen,
die von diesem Gerät erfasst werden.
Und umso besser sie sind, umso mehr
Ausschläge habe ich hier oben.
D.h.,
ich habe mich darauf konzentriert.
Dann geht meine Meditation hoch.
Wenn ich z.B. überlegen muss,
was ich sagen will ...
Jetzt kann ich gerade mal probieren,
ob es wieder steigt.
Siehst du? Jetzt geht es hoch.
Ich fange an, mich zu konzentrieren.
Wenn ich ein EEG
mit 32 Ablesepunkten habe
anstatt nur einem,
kann ich natürlich
deutlich mehr Effizienz rausholen.
In der utopischen Vorstellung,
dass ich das je schaffen sollte,
könnte ich mich setzen
und alles steuern,
ohne einen Finger krumm zu machen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich gehe davon aus, dass wir
mit der Technik verschmelzen.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass es unabdingbar ist.
Und ich gehe davon aus,
dass es in einer gewissen Zeit
tatsächlich so normal ist,
dass man sich eher wundert,
dass es nicht früher passiert ist.
Der Chip funktioniert tadellos.
Die Schwellung ist weg,
das Wundwasser ist weg.
Er macht seinen Dienst einwandfrei.
Ich bekomme konstante Körper-
temperaturwärme von der Stelle.
Ich bin mehr als zufrieden.
Es hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Ich möchte meinen Körper
jederzeit überwachen können.
Also meine Motivation
ist die Medizin.
Ich möchte jederzeit auf meinem iPad
- oder was auch immer ich benutze -
alles sehen,
was in meinem Körper vorgeht -
von meinem Blutzucker
bis zu meiner Muskelentzündung,
bis
zu meiner Zahnfleischrückbildung,
bis zu meinem Haarwuchs, alles!
Ich möchte jeden Punkt nachvoll-
ziehen und auch steuern können.
* Sanfte Musik *
Möchtest du den Tod besiegen?
Ob ich den Tod besiegen möchte?
Wenn ich mutig bin:
ja, ganz ehrlich.
Wenn ich die Möglichkeit hätte,
ein echtes Leben
in der Unsterblichkeit zu verbringen
und meinen Tod
selbst bestimmen zu können,
das wäre wahrscheinlich das Grösste,
was ich erreichen könnte.
Und ich möchte es.
Ich könnte tatsächlich
mein Potenzial völlig ausschöpfen,
denn ich habe dieses Zeitfenster
nicht mehr.
Das ist der Kernpunkt,
wo wir hinwollen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Sehen Sie gleich im zweiten Teil:
Jetzt nochmals tief einatmen,
mein Schatz!
Ah!
Glück ist ein Status.
Es ist ein Moment.
Raus! Allen Druck raus!
Jawohl! Ah!
Sehen Sie jetzt im zweiten Teil:
Jetzt nochmals tief einatmen,
mein Schatz!
Ah!
Glück ist ein Status.
Es ist ein Moment.
Raus! Allen Druck raus!
Jawohl! Ah!
# I lose my heart, I lose my soul.
# I lose my mind, I lose my beat.
# I lose my click.
* Popmusik *
Tief einatmen!
- Aua!
Ah!
Ich bin mitten
in der Bimbo-Transformation.
Ich möchte meinen Körper
eigentlich so weit optimieren,
dass irgendwann alles an mir
ziemlich künstlich ist.
* Popmusik *
Ich bin Aviva Rocks, bin 28,
arbeite als Webcam-Girl
und Pornodarstellerin
und bin vor Kurzem
nach Spanien ausgewandert.
* Popmusik *
Ich glaube, ich bin als Person
allgemein nicht wirklich
für die Gesellschaft gemacht -
also weder mit meinem Aussehen
noch mit meiner Denkweise,
meiner Einstellung,
meinem Job oder sonst etwas.
Foto conmigo!
Thank you! Thank you very much!
- Bye!
Ich geniesse das schon ein bisschen.
Ich mag es, wenn ich auffalle
und im Mittelpunkt stehe.
Gracias!
- Muy bien!
Adios!
* Popmusik *
Mir gefällt einfach
dieses Künstliche -
so dieses Fake, dieses Barbie.
Man nennt mich eben auch Bimbo.
Bimbo-Girl, Bimbo-Doll.
Ich habe halt blonde Haare,
schöne, pinkfarbene Lippen.
Ja, am besten würde man sehen,
dass an mir alles gemacht ist.
Darum ist es für mich
auch noch zu wenig,
was ich an mir habe machen lassen.
Die Nase ist noch zu natürlich.
Die Lippen sind im Moment
wieder zu natürlich.
Diese muss ich
auch wieder nachspritzen,
also dass sie
wie ein Schlauchboot aussehen.
Ja, es ist ...
Am besten alles
ein bisschen übertreiben,
dann gefällt es mir.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ah, jetzt ist einer reingekommen!
Ich verdiene mein Geld hauptsächlich
mit meinen Webcam-Shows.
Also mein Hauptjob ist Camgirl.
Nebenbei mache ich meine Pornoclips.
Tschüss!
Die sexuelle Lust
ist bei mir immer da.
Diese Veranlagung musst du haben.
Wenn eine sagt:
"Einmal Sex im Monat reicht mir!",
sage ich: "Ich glaube, Camgirl
ist nicht das Richtige für dich."
"Ich glaube,
du musst einen anderen Job haben."
Ja, du musst halt schon
Freude daran haben.
Also mein Ziel ist wirklich,
so gut wie nichts Natürliches mehr
an meinem Körper zu haben.
Bimbo ist einfach Plastik -
eben die Doll.
Barbie ist auch Plastik.
Das ist auch nicht echt.
Und sich dann halt auch so benehmen.
Also ein bisschen das Dummchen,
nicht ganz so intelligent.
Eine Puppe ist innen hohl.
Und Bimbo wird als Puppe,
als Doll, bezeichnet.
Und somit ist er halt auch hohl.
Am schönsten wäre natürlich
der Style einer Hummel:
eine richtig schlanke Taille,
hier XXL-Brüste und einen XXL-Arsch.
Und ich denke,
wenn ich mal alles operiert habe,
fängt alles wieder von vorne an:
Ich muss hier und dort
wieder etwas straffen.
Aber mir macht es ja zum Glück
Freude.
Einfach, dass ich weiss:
Jetzt kann ich mir wieder
eine OP leisten -
mit meinem verdienten Geld.
Ich kann hingehen,
wache auf und weiss,
dass ich wieder anders aussehe.
Und ich habe wieder etwas mehr
und bin meinem Ziel
von meinem eigenen Schönheitsideal
wieder etwas näher.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
das Adrenalin,
das man dann ausschüttet,
oder wie man das nennen will -
halt wie beim Tattoo:
Es ist zwar schmerzhaft,
aber man freut sich so sehr,
dass man es immer wieder will.
Ich würde schon sagen,
dass ich süchtig bin.
Kaum habe ich etwas operiert,
schaue ich,
was ich als Nächstes
operieren könnte.
Das ist schon eine Sucht, ja.
Das ist von meiner letzten Nasen-OP
mit der Stirnlift.
Da sieht man noch,
wo es angezeichnet wurde.
Dort haben sie aufgeschnitten.
Das war nach der letzten Brust-OP.
Die Heilung ist immer extrem mühsam.
Du darfst nichts machen.
Ich darf auch jetzt
keinen Sport treiben.
Du darfst zu Beginn
gar nichts machen:
kaum gehen, dich nicht bücken,
nichts hochheben.
Du kannst im Haushalt nichts machen.
Das nervt!
Das nervt von allem am meisten.
Aber trotzdem
hast du schnell wieder Lust,
wieder etwas zu machen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ja, wann habe ich damit angefangen?
Ich war schon früh ein Fan davon.
Lolo Ferrari war natürlich ...
Das war in den 90er-Jahren.
Damals war ich relativ jung.
Ich himmelte sie
aber immer schon an -
also schon,
als ich acht Jahre alt war.
Ich habe im Fernsehen Dokus gesehen.
Dann kamen immer wieder solche.
Ich fand das einfach so interessant.
Ich sagte zu mir:
"Ich muss das einfach auch haben."
Und darum dachte ich:
"So, ich muss meinen Job wechseln!"
So kam ich zu Porno und Webcam.
Ich wollte damit
einfach Geld verdienen.
Und so ergab sich das alles.
Ich konnte eines nach dem anderen
operieren.
Ich spare jeweils wieder
ein halbes oder ganzes Jahr,
um das Nächste zu operieren.
Also das ist ungefähr ...
... sechs, sieben Jahre her.
Das ist ziemlich genau
sechs Jahre her.
Sechs Jahre.
Damals hatte ich schon meine Dogge,
aber als Baby.
Gott sei Dank
sehe ich nicht mehr so aus!
Ich finde das ganz schlimm!
Ich fühlte mich damals
auch nicht wohl und nicht hübsch.
Nichts!
Nein, ich bin ganz froh,
dass ich nicht mehr so aussehe.
Es wäre schlecht, wenn ich mich
jetzt ansehen und sagen würde:
"Scheisse, was habe ich da gemacht?"
Es gibt Essen.
Ja, ich habe noch
Muttertagsgeschenke - zum Verwöhnen.
Geschenke? Oh, danke schön!
- Du darfst es schon auspacken.
Ja, ich bin dran!
Hetz nicht so!
Wow!
- Ja.
Ui!
Mir persönlich gefällt es nicht.
Mir gefiel sie als mein Kind
natürlich besser.
Letztlich muss sie es wissen -
genauso, wie ich mein Leben lebe.
Sie redet mir auch nicht drein.
Sie kann mir zwar Tipps geben,
aber ob ich diese umsetze
oder nicht, ist mir überlassen.
Genauso kann auch ich zu ihr sagen,
ich fände es nicht so gut.
Aber mal davon abgesehen: Wenn ich
mich aufrege oder was weiss ich,
bringt es sowieso nichts.
Dann macht sie es erst recht.
Also lasse ich sie.
Sie soll sich wohlfühlen.
Irgendwann
merkt sie es vielleicht selbst.
Wenn nicht, wird es ihr so gefallen,
dass sie es durchzieht.
Dann ist es ja auch richtig.
* Rockmusik *
# Bang!
Ich bin endlich - nach genau vier
Monaten, habe ich ausgerechnet -
in die Schweiz gekommen,
um mich generalüberholen zu lassen,
denn ich habe es nötig.
Die Lippen sind viel zu klein.
Hier ist nichts mehr.
Die Haare sind vom Chlor
und Meerwasser ganz schlimm.
Und es gibt noch etwas Farbe
unter die Haut.
Das alles muss einfach sein.
# Bang, sayonara, bang!
Ich habe etwas Angst.
Es tut jedes Mal weh.
Die Tränen werden fliessen,
aber ich werde mich freuen,
dass ich endlich wieder so richtig,
richtig fette Lippen habe.
Ich mache sie so dick, dass ich
nicht mehr aus den Augen sehe.
# I've got an army in my head.
# My bullet brains.
Hallo!
Endlich bist du da!
- Ja.
Wie geht's?
- Gut! Gut siehst du aus!
Danke gleichfalls!
- Ja.
Machen wir heute die Lippen
und die Wangen?
Genau.
Du musst mal schauen.
Vielleicht hat es noch ein wenig.
Ja.
Ich will eigentlich wirklich Lippen
wie ein Cartoonfisch.
Das ist so
die perfekte Beschreibung.
Das Schlauchboot ...
- Also alles andere als natürlich?
Genau! Man soll aus 3 km sehen:
"Okay, sie hat Gummi in den Lippen."
Dann ist es richtig.
Da wirst du mich jetzt lieben.
Jetzt nochmals tief einatmen,
mein Schatz!
Ganz tief einatmen! Super!
- Aua!
Es ist auch ein Adrenalinschmerz,
der süchtig macht.
Es ist vergleichbar
mit dem Tätowieren.
Im Moment stirbst du
und denkst jedes Mal: "Warum?"
"Warum mache ich das?"
- Ja.
"Warum tue ich meinem Körper das an?
Warum?"
Und sobald es fertig ist, denkst du:
"Geil!
Zum Glück habe ich es gemacht!"
"Ich sehe wieder so schön aus!"
Und du denkst:
"Wann komme ich wieder?"
Ja!
"Wann geht's weiter?
Was könnte ich noch machen?"
"Was ist das Nächste?"
Aber die Lippen
sind am schmerzhaftesten.
Das stimmt, ja.
Aber du machst das super!
Auf dieser Seite
spritze ich noch ein bisschen.
Ja, super!
Deine neuen Lippen.
Ja, so habe ich das gewollt!
- Sehr schön!
Morgen
wird es noch extremer aussehen.
Ja, das ist definitiv so.
Aber ich liebe es,
den Einstich zu sehen.
Ich liebe das.
Wirklich?
- Ja, ich mag das sehr.
Du spinnst.
- Ja, absolut!
* Sanfte Musik *
Das ist
eine völlige Selbstoptimierung -
von meinem Körper,
von meinem Aussehen, für mein Leben,
für mein Glücklichsein,
damit ich zufrieden sein kann.
Ja, absolut!
* Sanfte Musik *
Jetzt gibt es neue Haare.
Es gibt neue Haare!
Wow, diese Auswahl!
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich glaube, der Bimbo-Lifestyle
ist etwas vom Teuersten ...
... was es gibt, nehme ich an.
Neben dem Bodybuilding,
was ich so von Freundinnen höre,
ist Bimbo-Lifestyle etwas
vom Kostspieligsten, das es gibt.
Man muss halt woanders
Abstriche machen und viel dafür tun.
Aber es muss jeder selber wissen,
was wichtig ist.
Mir macht das Freude,
einem anderen Fünf-Gänge-Menüs
für 100 Fr. oder 200 Fr. zu essen.
Ich lasse mir für dieses Geld
lieber die Haare machen.
Wenn man sich operieren lässt oder
etwas an seinem Körper vornimmt,
sollte man es nur
für sich selbst tun,
also nur sich selbst
glücklich machen
und es nicht für irgendeinen Mann,
Auftritt oder Fans machen.
Es ist schön,
wenn meine Fans Freude haben
und es mit mir zusammen
geniessen können,
aber nur, weil einer sagt,
ich solle das und das machen,
würde ich es nie tun.
* Sanfte Musik *
Eben!
Das ist immer das Schlimmste.
Also, es geht los.
Du sagst einfach ...
Ja.
* Sanfte Musik *
Oh!
Ich gestalte so
einfach meinen Körper, mein ...
... ja, mein Ich.
Ich gestalte es so,
wie es mir gefällt -
ob das jetzt mit OPs ist
oder mit kosmetischen Eingriffen,
Tätowierungen, Haare färben,
Make-up, Kleidern ...
Ich mache es so, wie es mir gefällt.
Ich musste schon meine ID erneuern.
Sie hatten an der Grenze
mein Gesicht nicht mehr erkannt,
mit den Gesichtszügen ...
- Oh!
Ja, voll krass!
* Sanfte Musik *
Privat höre ich halt so Death Metal,
Thrash Metal, New Metal ...
Ich höre viele Metal-Stile.
Und mir gefällt alles,
was mit Grusel zu tun hat,
mit Totenköpfen,
Horrorsachen und Splattersachen,
blutiges Zeug.
Das gehört halt auch ein bisschen
zu meiner Persönlichkeit.
Ich hatte - Gott sei Dank -
eine sehr schöne Kindheit.
Ich durfte bei meinen Grosseltern
aufwachsen.
An den Wochenenden
durfte ich bei meinen Eltern sein.
Sie arbeiteten beide zu 100 %.
Viele glauben auch,
dass Leute, die sich so umgestalten,
eine schlimme Kindheit,
irgendein Trauma
oder so etwas hatten.
Ich kann mit Glück sagen,
dass ich so etwas nicht hatte.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich bin total happy! Total!
Total!
Jetzt sehe ich mein wahres Ich,
denn allmählich sehe ich so aus,
wie ich mich fühle.
Vorher hatte ich immer schlimme
Komplexe und fühlte mich nicht wohl.
Ich war nicht zufrieden mit mir.
Jetzt habe ich einfach Freude.
Ich kann darüber reden, es zeigen,
meine Erfahrungen
mit den Operationen,
mit den Eingriffen mitteilen.
Jetzt bin ich ich, was ich vorher,
ohne die Eingriffe, nicht war.
* Sanfte Musik *
Bimbo oder auch das Aussehen ist
auch das, was mich glücklich macht,
dass ich so aussehen kann,
wie ich will,
dass ich noch mit 50 so aussehen
kann, wie ich mir das vorstelle,
wie ich mir das wünsche
und wie es mir gefällt,
und nicht denke:
"Oh nein! Wie sehe ich aus?"
Das ist natürlich schon das Ziel:
dass ich das auch mit 50 habe, ja.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Beschwingte Musik *
# You've got to change
your evil ways, baby.
# Baby.
* Sphärische Musik *
Mein Name ist Mischa Janiec.
Ich bin 27 Jahre alt.
Ich bin Natural Bodybuilder
und Online-Unternehmer.
Täglich
verfolgen über 500'000 Leute
meinen Weg in den sozialen Medien.
Mein Motto ist:
jeden Tag ein Stück besser werden.
Ich stehe hier
vor dem Mekka of Bodybuilding:
vor dem Gold's Gym in Venice,
wo eine Legende trainiert hat:
Arnold Schwarzenegger himself.
Er ist eine grosse Inspiration
für mich.
Heute trainieren wir
mit einem sehr bekannten Natural
Bodybuilder, mit Simeon Panda.
Ich glaube, er ist das bekannteste
Gesicht in diesem Sport,
in dieser Szene. Er hat
auf Instagram über 4 Mio. Follower.
Da siehst du,
wie gross diese Szene schon ist.
You look massive!
Yeah!
* Popmusik *
Ich wollte einfach mal wissen,
wie er trainiert.
Die Leute sagen,
ich hätte einen krassen Rücken.
Aber sieht man seinen Rücken,
denkt man: "Das ist nicht möglich!"
Ich dachte,
er könne mir noch Tipps geben.
Auch nach neun Jahren
geht immer noch mehr.
Du kannst immer noch versuchen,
besser zu werden.
Die Leute limitieren sich und sagen,
es gebe ein genetisches Limit.
Dieses sei nach zwei
oder zehn Jahren erreicht.
Ich glaube, es ist erst erreicht,
wenn du sagst, es sei erreicht,
wenn du mit dir selbst
abgeschlossen hast und sagst:
"Das ist es gewesen.
Ich werde nicht mehr besser."
Dann wirst du
auch nicht mehr besser.
Aber gehst du mit dem Mindset rein:
"Es geht noch was!", wieso nicht?
Daher musst du dir immer Leute
suchen, die besser sind als du.
120 kg ... Mehr, 125 kg!
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Let's do this!
Look at that!
Nice!
* Popmusik *
* Stöhnen *
Ich muss eigentlich auch
in die Cam gucken.
Ja, gerne!
Wir versuchen gerade, ein geeignetes
Thumbnail fürs Video zu finden.
Das ist das Bild,
das man auf YouTube sieht.
Wenn das möglichst optimiert,
möglichst klickgeil ist,
kann das zehnmal mehr Klicks
ausmachen.
* Popmusik *
Ah!
Uh!
Ja, ja, genau!
Ja, das ist gut!
Alles, was du nicht filmst,
ist nicht dokumentiert.
Das ist wie bei der Geschichte:
Alles, was wir heutzutage wissen,
wissen wir,
weil es irgendjemand
aufgeschrieben hat.
Die Bibel beispielsweise:
Die Sachen mit Jesus wissen wir nur,
weil sie jemand aufgeschrieben hat.
Filmen wir es nicht,
wird es nur in unserem Hirn bleiben.
Das ist auch schön,
aber will man es teilen,
muss man es dokumentieren.
Darum filmen wir es.
Bodybuilding steht noch immer
in einem negativen Licht.
Es ist
ein sehr oberflächlicher Sport.
Aber ich finde,
wenn man die Tendenz dazu hat,
sich mit sich selbst
zu beschäftigen ...
Du reflektierst dich
ja auch im Spiegel,
wenn du trainierst.
Das reflektiert auch in die Seele.
Ich habe gemerkt:
Du kannst so viel an dir verbessern,
was über deinen Körper hinausgeht.
Ich will den Leuten mehr geben
als nur zu zeigen,
wie man ein Sixpack
oder dicken Bizeps bekommt.
* Popmusik *
Wir sind gestern
von Hawaii zurückgekommen.
Vor 8, 9 Std. sind wir eingeflogen.
So!
Mhm, ja!
Er schmeckt so wie jeden Tag.
Kaffee ist für mich auch wichtig.
Das ist ein Ritual.
Wenn ich schon nonstop
unterwegs bin,
will ich wenigstens am Morgen
ein Ritual haben,
das ich überall machen kann -
egal, ob ich mal
in der Zeitzone von Hawaii bin.
Jetzt sind wir hier.
Es ist 11 Uhr.
Eigentlich wäre erst 7 Uhr.
Aber meinen Kaffee trinke ich
einfach immer nach dem Aufstehen.
In der ersten Stunde nach
dem Aufstehen kommt mein Kaffee.
So habe ich wenigstens etwas
in meinem Alltag, das konstant ist.
Einer meiner biggest steps
letztes oder dieses Jahr war es,
die Schweiz zu verlassen,
weil ich
in den letzten beiden Jahren
keine zwei Monate mehr
in der Schweiz war.
Ich nütze die Infrastruktur
in der Schweiz nicht mehr,
habe aber dennoch noch zwei Jahre
brav meine Steuern bezahlt.
Dieses Jahr habe ich gesagt:
"Das mache ich nicht mehr."
Ich war staatenlos.
Ich habe mich beraten lassen.
Nachher
meldete ich mich in Panama an.
Da spare ich
natürlich sehr viele Steuern.
* Rockmusik *
Ich habe immer eine Regel:
Wenn ich nicht mindestens zehn Tage
an einem Ort bleibe,
packe ich gar nicht aus.
Man könnte das
"Digital Nomade" nennen.
Das hat vielleicht schon mal jemand
gehört: der digitale Nomade.
D.h., Thailand und Südafrika
z.B. für die günstigen sechs Monate,
in denen man Geld spart,
wenn man so will,
weil man in der Schweiz
viel mehr ausgibt als in Thailand.
Und dann komme ich hierher
und gebe das Achtfache aus -
also doppelt so viel, wie ich
in der Schweiz ausgeben würde.
Ich kann es mir aber auch leisten,
weil ich sechs Monate im Jahr
in günstigen Regionen lebe.
Wenn ich zurückblicke,
bin ich in den letzten drei Jahren
in 25 bis 30 verschiedenen Ländern
und in etwa 60 Cities gewesen.
Es wirkt von aussen schon so:
Was geht da ab?
Der einzige Grund,
dass ich mir das leisten kann,
ist natürlich, weil ich meine Skills
so weit ausgebildet habe,
dass sie schwer von jemand anderem
zu kopieren sind.
D.h., ich habe mir
erst mal einen Skill angeeignet,
der eben über dieses normale
Fitnesstrainer-Niveau hinausgeht.
Ich habe begonnen, mich wissen-
schaftlich damit auseinanderzusetzen
und habe natürlich auch gesehen,
dass dieser Skill sehr gefragt war.
Ich bin in diese Szene
hineingewachsen.
Und gleichzeitig ist das Medium,
über das ich das Ganze
transportiert habe,
also die sozialen Medien,
auch im richtigen Moment explodiert.
Das ist der Leverage,
den ich damit kreiert habe,
dass ich nicht im Gym bin
und eine Person trainiere,
sondern einen Onlinekurs mache,
den in den ersten beiden Jahren
über 4'000 Leute gekauft haben.
Jetzt, in den letzten beiden Jahren,
sind nochmals 3'000 bis 4'000
dazugekommen.
D.h., ich habe mittlerweile
über 8'000 Leute,
die meine Programme gemacht haben.
Und diese verkaufe ich im Schnitt
für 150 Fr. bis 250 Fr.
* Popmusik *
Uh!
Als ich bei Orange arbeitete,
erklärten mich die Leute
für verrückt.
"Was? Du kündigst deine Stelle?"
Mein Lohn war nicht schlecht.
"Und das nur für YouTube-Videos?
Wie willst du denn Geld verdienen?"
Sie begriffen das damals nicht.
Heute sagen dieselben Leute:
"Mischa, du hattest Glück!"
* Popmusik *
Momentan reist Marcel mit uns.
Marcel filmt mich halt nonstop.
Wenn ich ins Gym oder essen gehe
oder ein Storyvideo drehe,
filmt er, schneidet den Film
und lädt ihn auf YouTube hoch.
D.h., ich habe viel weniger zu tun.
Wenn du im Leben
wirklich weiterkommen willst,
musst du deine Zeit definitiv
als wertvoll betrachten -
wertvoller als Geld - und sie
nur noch ganz gezielt einsetzen.
D.h., ich schaue,
dass ich Leute wie Marcel dabeihabe,
dass ich Online-Assistants habe -
ich habe drei,
die gewisse Sachen
für mich übernehmen.
So kann ich morgens aufstehen
und erst einmal lesen.
So kann ich auch täglich
meine 2 Std. im Gym haben.
So kann ich mich auch
mit Leuten treffen
und Geschäftsmeetings machen,
was ich auch sehr wichtig finde.
Und gleichzeitig kann ich auch
ein guter Boyfriend bleiben,
denn sonst ist man
ein überarbeiteter Workaholic.
Und das will ich gar nicht sein.
Ich finde, das ist einer
meiner wichtigsten Faktoren,
was Selbstoptimierung betrifft,
denn in dem Moment,
in dem du
aus dem Hamsterrad ausbrichst ...
Für gewisse Leute ist das Hamsterrad
eine Karriereleiter.
Aber wenn man aussteigt
und es sich von der Seite ansieht,
sieht man,
dass es sich im Kreis dreht.
Du kannst als CEO
oder Vice president
noch so viel Geld verdienen -
du wirst es nie ausgeben können.
Du wirst nie wirklich
diesen Spass haben können.
Und wenn du in das Alter kommst,
in dem es so weit wäre,
ist die Frage,
ob du das noch willst.
* Popmusik *
The third to the left.
- The third to the left, okay!
Hello!
- Hi there! Mischa?
Yes.
Okay, go ahead!
Go ahead! Lie here on your back!
And then lie yourself
on that middle line!
DEXA-Scan.
D.h., du scannst den ganzen Körper
und bekommst nachher
gewisse Angaben zu deinem Körper,
z.B. Körperfett, Knochendichte.
Ich habe z.B. Skoliose.
Da ist für mich interessant:
Kommt meine linke Seite mit meiner
rechten nach, wenn ich trainiere?
Das jetzige Ergebnis ist auch
für die Muskelmasse interessant.
Hat sich etwas getan?
Das ist natürlich jedes Mal
die Hoffnung.
Ich weiss,
dass sich etwas getan hat,
aber ich will es
auch noch auf dem Papier haben.
Wow!
Das sind 2 kg in einem Jahr.
Vegan.
Vegan 2,5 kg Muskeln aufgebaut.
Juhu!
* Popmusik *
Ich habe jetzt einen Call
mit David Goldman.
Das ist ein Facharzt
fürs Thema Lebensverlängerung.
Life Extension.
Das ist sehr interessant.
* Popmusik *
Bye-bye!
No, but you know what I mean.
- Yeah, I know what you mean.
In den ersten vier, fünf Jahren war
das Einzige, was mich interessierte,
wie ich noch muskulöser werden kann.
Jetzt geht es mir eher darum:
Wie kann ich noch gesünder werden?
Wie kann ich meinen Alltag
um dieses ganze Ding aufbauen?
Dadurch,
dass ich jetzt auch reise ...
Ich habe ja schon
die bewusste Entscheidung getroffen,
dass das nicht mehr mein Leben ist,
sonst wäre ich in meiner Wohnung
in der Schweiz,
würde meine fünf Mahlzeiten pro Tag
kochen
und täglich im David Gym trainieren
- no pain, no gain.
Das habe ich abgeschafft.
Darum versuche ich jetzt,
immer noch das Optimum
herauszuholen,
aber es ist definitiv
nicht mehr alles in meinem Leben.
Nein, sie hat recht: Es ist wichtig.
Wenn ich an einen Ort fliege
und mehr als eine Woche dortbleibe,
muss es ein gutes Gym geben,
sonst habe ich ein Problem.
* Popmusik *
Ich selber konsumiere am Feierabend
manchmal Marihuana.
* Popmusik *
Man muss schon sagen:
Jeder Wirkstoff -
Koffein, Marihuana, Alkohol ...
Es gibt Leute, die diese Wirkstoffe
besser vertragen,
und Leute,
die sie nicht so gut vertragen.
Daher ist Cannabis für viele Leute
typenabhängig keine gute Option.
Und Alkohol hat das Problem -
nicht für jeden, aber für mich -,
dass er sehr viele Kalorien enthält.
Viele Leute sind sich nicht bewusst,
dass Alkohol pro Gramm
sieben Kilokalorien hat.
Das ist fast so viel wie Fett.
Selbstoptimierung heisst für mich,
nicht allem fernzubleiben,
sondern alles mal auszuprobieren
und herauszufinden:
Ist das etwas für mich?
Bringt es mich weiter?
Wie wenn man ein Videogame
und einen Joystick hat:
Du drückst mal alle Knöpfe
und schaust, was passiert.
Und wenn du deine Knöpfe in den
richtigen Momenten bewusst einsetzt,
kann dich das sehr weit bringen.
* Popmusik *
Perfektion ist ein Ziel,
das sich jederzeit wegbewegt.
Sobald du an dem Punkt bist, an dem
du gedacht hast, es sei perfekt,
wirst du realisieren,
dass es nicht perfekt ist.
D.h., einer Perfektion nachzueifern,
ist sehr gefährlich
und kann dazu führen,
dass du dich an einem
unglücklichen Ort wiederfindest.
* Popmusik *
Ich selber habe die Challenge,
meine Glücklichkeit zu behalten.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es
mehr oder weniger Glück gibt.
Glück ist ein Status.
Es ist ein Moment.
Und weil man Glück
eben meistens innen findet,
finde ich es eben auch
ein sehr gutes Ziel,
einfach weiterhin glücklich zu sein.
* Popmusik *
* Sanfte Musik *
Dann kannst du die Beine
auch mal nach oben nehmen -
zum Himmel.
So ein bisschen ausstrecken,
die Arme dazunehmen
und mal die Fuss- und Handgelenke
rausschütteln.
Die Knie bewegen.
Aus der Hüfte heraus
die Beine, Arme, Ellbogen
und Schultern bewegen.
Mal richtig alles rausschütteln!
Alle Anspannung raus!
Allen Druck raus! Jawohl! Ah!
Kräftig! Ah!
Ah! Und nochmals!
Und alles raus! Ah! Ja!
Wunderbar! Sehr gut!
* Sanfter Gesang *
Ich war im Management von grossen,
internationalen Konzernen tätig.
Ich merkte über die Jahre hinweg:
Der Druck wird einfach zu gross.
Ich arbeite sehr viel und entferne
mich immer mehr von meiner Essenz.
Viel Geld verdienen, immer eine
höhere Rendite haben, mehr Profit -
die klassischen Themen
in der Wirtschaft.
Die Befriedigung
wurde immer weniger.
Am Ende
kumulierte es sich im Körperlichen.
Ich wurde krank.
Dann bekam ich
die klassischen Stresssymptome:
Anspannung, Druck,
Schlafstörungen, Aggressivität.
Ich bekam dann auch
eine schwere Hirnblutung.
Das war für mich ein Zeichen,
dass es so nicht mehr weitergeht.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Sanfter Gesang *
Deine Schultern dürfen noch
ein bisschen mehr zum Boden sinken,
weich werden.
* Sanfter Gesang *
Wie zentral ist es,
an sich zu arbeiten,
sich weiterzuentwickeln,
oder man könnte auch sagen,
sich selber zu optimieren?
Ich glaube,
es ist schon sehr essenziell.
Es ist die Frage:
In welcher Phase meines Lebens
stehe ich?
Habe ich die Ressourcen dazu?
Habe ich die Kraft dazu?
Habe ich die Zeit dazu?
Und was ich oft beobachte:
Ist der Druck gross genug,
um etwas zu ändern?
Es braucht schon auch immer wieder
einen Einfluss von aussen.
Es muss etwas passieren, damit ich
reflektiere: Geht es so weiter?
Möchte ich so weiterleben?
Oder kann ich an mir etwas ändern?
* Sanfte Musik *
Mein Mantra, das ich immer
von meiner Mutter gehört habe ...
Ich liebe meine Mutter,
ihr wisst es ja:
"Oh,
was sollen die Nachbarn denken?"
"Mit deinen zerrissenen Hosen,
deiner komischen Musik
und deinem komischen Auto
mit all den Bierdosen?"
Wie es halt so ist
damals auf dem Dorf:
"Was sollen denn
die Nachbarn denken?"
Aber wenn ich das so absorbiere,
lebe ich nicht mein Leben,
sondern dasjenige meiner Nachbarn.
Ich mache mich über diese Menschen
nicht lustig.
Ihr versteht das.
Wenn die Prägung so stark ist,
ist es schwierig, da rauszukommen.
Also: Ich erkenne diese Prägung,
diesen Glaubenssatz.
Und jetzt übe ich, den anzunehmen.
Ich will halt beliebt sein.
Ich kann nicht Nein sagen.
Oder: Ja, ich bin pedantisch.
Ich bin perfekt.
Und ich muss das alles
zum 13. Mal nachrechnen.
Das ist jetzt so.
Dann übe ich eben, das umzuwandeln.
Möchtest du nach vorne kommen?
Möchtest du dich mal so hinstellen,
wie du dich wohlfühlst?
Ist der Abstand so in Ordnung?
- Es ist okay.
Gut!
Du kannst die Augen mal schliessen.
Und jetzt ganz bewusst
die Füsse wahrnehmen,
ein bisschen Kontakt
mit dem Boden haben.
Die Aufrichtung wahrnehmen.
Die Schultern ausrotieren.
Führe den Hinterkopf
noch ein Stück mehr nach hinten!
Nimm wahr, wie du jetzt dastehst:
geerdet, kraftvoll ...
... ganz stabil, fest.
Und während du so atmest,
bist du ganz bei dir.
Ich lese dir jetzt Sätze vor.
Lass diese einfach auf dich wirken
und schau, was passiert!
"Ich akzeptiere,
was ich nicht ändern kann."
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
"Störungen sind Teil des Jobs."
"Ich bleibe gelassen,
auch wenn ich nicht weiss,
was kommt."
Gut!
Gibt es da einen Satz,
bei dem du eine Resonanz spürst,
einen Satz, der dich anspricht?
Ja.
- Möchtest du ihn sagen?
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Sehr schön!
Sag den Satz nochmals - auf Mundart.
So, wie es für dich stimmig ist.
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Mal tief einatmen!
Und sag den Satz nochmals!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Sag den Satz lauter!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Noch lauter!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Und kräftig! Laut!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Leg mal deine linke Hand
auf dein Herz
und die rechte auf die linke Hand!
Sag den Satz nochmals!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Jawohl.
Gut.
Vielen, herzlichen Dank
für die schöne Übung!
Was hast du im Verlauf der Übung
wahrgenommen?
Dass es mir leichter fiel,
den Satz zu sagen,
aber noch nicht ganz so ruhig,
wie ich ihn hätte sagen sollen.
Diesen Satz ...
Wie lautet dein Satz?
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Den wiederholst du jetzt jeden Tag!
Kennst du diese Post-it-Zettel?
Du klebst sie auf
deinen Kühlschrank. Was steht drauf?
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Genau! Dann öffnest du
den Spiegelschrank im Badezimmer.
Dort klebt ein Post-it -
mit welchem Satz?
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Genau! Dann öffnest du die Tür
deines Kleiderschranks.
Es ist 12.15 Uhr. Wir müssen essen.
* Lachen *
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Die Zeit ist egal.
* Kirchenglocke *
* Sanfter, kirchlicher Gesang *
Und je mehr ich in die Ruhe komme,
je mehr ich eben diese Gedanken
und den Geist zur Ruhe bringe,
desto mehr komme ich bei mir an.
Und gerade in unserer Gesellschaft,
die sehr stark
durch materielle Dinge geprägt ist,
materiellen Wohlstand,
Glücksversprechen im Aussen,
ist es nicht einfach.
Und oft erkenne ich auch,
wenn ich mit meinen Klienten
intensiver zusammenarbeite:
Ich liebe Orte des Rückzugs -
einfache, im Kloster.
Dort blühen sie auf.
* Sanfter, kirchlicher Gesang *
Ich hatte ein Schlüsselerlebnis,
das mich sehr stark prägte:
Ich wurde schwer krank
und lag im Krankenhaus.
Es war nicht klar,
ob ich diese Nacht überleben würde.
Ich verspürte eine ganz tiefe Ruhe
und einen grossen Frieden.
Und das war das erste Mal,
dass ich spürte ...
Ich kann es nicht in Worte fassen -
damals nicht, heute nicht.
Aber ich spürte: Es wird alles gut
oder es ist schon alles gut.
Und das war für mich
eine wichtige Erfahrung,
dass ich vertrauen darf.
Und es war für mich auch
eine wichtige Erfahrung,
dass da etwas ist,
was ich lange, lange gesucht habe,
auch wenn ich es nicht
in Worte fassen kann.
Und das möchte ich
näher kennenlernen und erkunden.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Er atmet laut. *
Kommt meine Arbeit
bei den Leuten an?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich vergleiche es ...
... mit einem kleinen Samen,
der gepflanzt oder gesät wird.
Aus diesem Samen
kommt ein kleines Pflänzchen,
das gegossen und gepflegt
werden muss.
Und irgendwann
kommt da ein Pflänzchen raus,
irgendwann eine kleine Blüte.
So sehe ich auch meine Arbeit.
Am Ende kann ich keinem Menschen
helfen oder ihn retten.
Das ist auch nicht mein Anspruch,
das wäre vermessen.
Was ich Menschen mitgeben kann,
ist eben eine andere Sichtweise.
Ich kann ihnen
meine Erfahrung schildern,
Übungen und Techniken mitgeben
und Sichtweisen aus
asiatischen Wissenslehren zeigen.
Ist der Platz hier okay?
Willst du dich woanders hinlegen?
Wo möchtest du deinen Kopf hinlegen?
Genau! Dann bringe ich dir noch
ein Kopfkissen oder eine Decke.
Hast du einen sensiblen Rücken?
Möchtest du was
unter die Knie nehmen?
Nein, es ist gut so.
- Möchtest du dich zudecken?
Nein.
- Gut.
Dann komme mal ganz bewusst
in deinem Körper an!
Nimm den Körper wahr!
Nimm wahr,
wie dein Körper jetzt schwer wird!
Dein Kiefer ist locker.
Deine Zähne berühren sich nicht.
Was lastet auf dir?
Auf deinem unteren Rücken?
Wie alt warst du da?
14, 15, ja.
Wo stehst du jetzt
in diesem Elternhaus?
In deinem Zimmer?
- Ja.
Was braucht Patty
jetzt in dem Moment,
wo sie in diesem Zimmer steht
und weiss, es ist viel zu viel?
Zu viele Schulaufgaben, Arbeit,
dann für den Vater
noch da sein müssen oder wollen.
Was braucht Patty?
Was braucht sie?
- Leichtigkeit.
Leichtigkeit.
Möchtest du jetzt
als starke, erwachsene Frau
mit der ganzen Kraft, die du hast,
zu Patty gehen
und sie fest in den Arm nehmen?
Möchtest du ihr sagen,
dass du für sie da bist?
Ja, gut! Lass dir Zeit!
Wie reagiert sie?
Gut, schön!
Bitte?
- Sie muss auch weinen.
Sie muss weinen, jawohl.
Darf sie weinen?
Gut.
Bitte?
Ja, genau.
Sie lächelt.
Wunderbar, das ist schön!
Dann lass die Augen
jetzt mal geschlossen
und atme mal ganz bewusst tief durch
die Nase ein - bis in den Bauch.
Kraftvoll!
Reibe deine Hände kräftig!
Noch mehr!
Und jetzt die Wangen,
die Ohren, den Kopf, Hinterkopf.
Kräftig! Alles kräftig reiben!
Und die Schultern!
Richtig ausstreichen!
Den Oberkörper!
Alles weg! Alles weg!
Noch mehr! Weg!
Alle Wut, alle Trauer,
der ganze Schmerz - weg!
Weg!
Trink mal einen Schluck Wasser!
- Ja.
Danke!
Lass dir Zeit!
Wo stehe ich auf meiner Reise?
Eine sehr gute Frage!
Ich ...
Ich sehe mich am Anfang.
Ich glaube,
es ist nie abgeschlossen.
Es ist ein ständiges Lernen
und Erfahren.
Sicherlich auch immer wieder
mit Rückschlägen verbunden,
auch mal mit einem Stillstand.
Aber es entwickelt sich
kontinuierlich etwas.
Man könnte salopp sagen:
Mein Zusammenbruch
war auch mein Glück,
dass sich da eine neue Tür öffnete.
Man könnte sagen:
"Jawohl, mit der Erfahrung,
die ich gesammelt habe -
im Positiven wie im Negativen -,
kann ich einen Schritt weitergehen
und etwas tun,
was anderen Menschen hilft,
sie unterstützt
und ihnen vielleicht
Orientierung bietet."